Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience
and we're live.
You don't have to wear headphones
if you don't want your Paul Stanley.
That's right.
What do you want to take a
shit on the floor over there?
You feel free.
Hey,
you know,
use your age if that's what turns you on.
But I would accept it.
I wouldn't even take photos of it.
I wouldn't even tell anybody.
I'm just putting Joe Rogan podcast.
You put it down on Twitter?
Yeah.
Okay.
He did it.
Beautiful.
All right,
we're live.
Good.
First of all,
I just want to say thank you
very much for being here at this.
When I was a little kid,
like I,
I've been a fan of kiss since.
I can't remember when I wasn't like I
was a tiny little kid when I first found
out about kiss.
So to have you here in my podcast,
I've been to many of your shows
both pre when you wore makeup.
Then when you got off of makeup and
then when he got back on makeup again.
So I've been through the full spectrum,
so low.
I had the solo albums.
I was there too.
You were there for the whole
thing through the whole thing.
Every show you were at.
I was at,
that's what I hear.
But that is a weird thing though,
that you like you guys,
um,
you broke up,
we're not broke up,
but you got rid of Chris and you got rid
of ace and then you brought in new guys
and now you kind of have
guys that play those roles.
Is that how you're doing it now?
I don't know that you,
you could,
I mean,
that's a tough one to answer.
You know,
I think where we went
astray is when we started,
when we first replaced Peter and we
decided we needed a new character.
And the problem with that kind of
stuff is that it started to become
interestingly,
I think,
disingenuous.
It,
it,
it took on an air of
fake in the sense that,
um,
it became a menagerie.
I mean,
we had a fox and a Egyptian warrior
next week would have turtle boy and the
frog,
the frog man.
So I think once we,
we brought a son Peter
back for the reunion tour,
which,
um,
I hoped we'd go on forever.
And in other words,
I hope that everybody
would get back together.
Um,
everybody would see the,
the,
the uh,
error in their ways and we would move
forward and stay together forever.
But when that wasn't to be,
I thought,
you know,
we really built these four images and
arguably you can go anywhere in the world
and people know who kisses regardless of
whether they know who those people are.
So to to give up that,
because we found that those guys were no
longer either capable or wanted to give
it 100% well who loses out the fans.
So no,
we,
you know,
those images are the images that will
continue when I'm not hearing either.
Yeah.
That's gotta be
a strange place to be where you and Jean
are bolt these super focused healthy
non drug using guys.
And then you have these two guys in
your band that are integral parts of the
band.
You know,
I mean,
Beth was a huge hit.
It was,
and look,
this,
this whole show could turn into
denigrating the former members,
but I don't want to do that.
But honestly,
um,
that song was the product of a great
producer who had a big hand in writing it
and a co writer who Peter used on a
lot of things that he supposedly wrote.
So,
um,
but they were integral
members of the band and,
uh,
it's very difficult to,
to move forward when two
of the people are like,
at times like flat tires,
you're trying to,
you're trying to move forward.
Um,
it becomes more of a problem when they're,
um,
re reason,
reason for being is to foil and,
and to,
um,
throw off track what you're trying to do.
So at some point it really became more
about trying to disrupt what we were
trying to do with no regard to whether
or not what they want to do was right or
wrong.
They just wanted,
let's screwed gene and Paul.
So we'll say no,
and they'll say yes.
So it really became very,
very,
very difficult.
So do you think they did that?
Because,
I mean,
did they have a logical reason?
Was it just because they were
self sabotaging the anyway,
I think self sabotaging comes into
it because I think that's been a,
something that's run through
parts of their lives.
But I also think that there was,
um,
a lot of resentment and honestly,
I don't believe in resenting people
for what they can do that you can't,
if you're lucky enough to have
people around you who can do what,
you can't make them your best friend.
You know?
I mean,
I learn from Oren and um,
everybody can't be,
you know,
everybody can't be the
best at what they do,
but you can benefit from
being around those people.
So look,
I,
I never wanted or expected anybody in the
band to do necessarily the same amount
of work that I did,
but I expected them to give 100%.
Everybody's,
you know,
I was all for splitting things evenly,
uh,
in the original lineup
of the band up until,
uh,
you know,
those guys departed the first time.
But,
um,
you have to give your best,
when you say like resent,
like resent for what you,
what they can't do.
But they were a great,
I mean,
Peter,
Chris was a fantastic drummer.
Ace freely was a great guitarist.
Who,
what would they resent
other than your sobriety
or your health?
I think focus and drive and determination.
Yeah.
Determination and seeing
the whole picture and,
and I'm wanting this to be as good as it
could be as opposed to falling back on
all,
you know,
it's rock and roll.
Well,
rock and roll is no excuse for mediocrity.
And rock and roll is no
excuse for not doing your job.
You know,
if somebody says,
Oh,
my playing is rock and roll.
No,
that's just bad.
You know,
it's bad.
And then there's rock and roll.
So,
um,
you know,
he,
look,
it's a long time ago and it's kind of
like talking about a girlfriend or a wife
you had a long time ago and trying to,
to disseminate what went wrong.
And at some point it
really doesn't matter.
Yeah.
It's,
it's always hard to deal with people
that are in that sort of self sabic
sabotaging mode.
And you see it all the time.
And one of the things that I always
equate to is when you see people smoking
cigarettes and they throw
their cigarette on the ground,
and I'll think anything of it.
And it's,
it's a super common thing.
It's very rare that you see people just
throw trash on the ground in front of
everybody.
But people will throw cigarettes on the
ground in front of anybody and they're
not there because they're
sabotaging their own body.
They don't mind just throwing
stuff on the ground too.
It's sort of the same kind
of a mentality I think.
So,
you know,
and perhaps if it's okay for me to smoke,
it's okay for me to discard my cigarette.
You're going to breed
the smoke second hand.
So here's a,
but you know,
so,
um,
I don't,
I really don't know.
I don't know them mentality that wants
to sabotage what ultimately benefits you.
Um,
look,
if you're in a band that's doing great
and you're not the primary songwriter
where the primary singer,
well you should revel in what you have.
Um,
um,
you know,
the idea of equality,
some have to be more equal than others,
you know,
um,
everybody can be in the car together,
somebody's got to drive,
we all,
we're all going the same direction.
But,
um,
you know,
when people reach a point of saying,
well,
I want an equal amount of songs while do
we leave off strider so we can put your
song on?
Or did we leave off Detroit rock city?
It doesn't work like that.
Um,
there's no,
I don't believe that
there's any birthright or,
or that,
that we should expect a quota in anything.
We,
we get what we deserve and,
uh,
somebody has to decide that.
So is that the most difficult thing about
being in a band is just managing all
the egos and managing,
you know,
everybody has their own
point of view where they're,
they're not getting appreciated or looked
at with the proper respect and that,
that,
that's often the situation in band.
And thankfully not the situation
in our band.
Um,
Eric's been in out of
the band for 20 years,
I think at this point.
And Tom,
he's been around the band
and been in the band.
Um,
I think over 10 at this point,
the key to a great band or any great
situation is doing what's best for the
situation,
not what's best for you.
I don't have to be right.
I just want to see the right thing happen.
So if you're more tied up in,
in the ego gratification
or in the control factor,
I honestly don't need to,
to control anything.
But I do have a point of view and
I guess I've earned my place at,
at this juncture.
But everybody gets a chance to,
to,
you know,
state their views and hopefully they're
always with the best intentions.
And I think that's what
the way the band works now,
um,
we have a drum or doesn't
like to take a solo and this,
this guy could play a better solar with
one hand and most drummers could play
with every limb of their body.
So everybody really,
um,
it's all for one.
And one for all.
You guys were one of the first bands
that got really big doing live shows like
your live shows were so spectacular
that when you put a live album out,
when you put out kiss alive and then
kiss alive to those albums were so big.
Like,
uh,
I mean,
and it's obviously we're
dating ourselves here,
but just the albums when you'd open up
kiss alive to that big silver dynamic
record.
I mean it was,
it was awesome and the performances were
so intense and it was so much fun to
listen to that it really
boosted you guys up.
And when I was a kid,
it would really drive me fucking crazy
that I didn't hear your songs enough on
the radio and what I did
here when your songs,
I got super excited.
I got pumped.
But it was always like
Detroit rock city or Beth.
It was never like cold gin or,
or one of the more obscure titles,
you know,
which cold gin.
Not a very obscure song.
But it was,
you guys became big almost in spite.
Yeah,
I have business.
Yeah.
And I think to this day,
we still retain a certain amount of being.
The black sheep were still,
look,
it took 14 years for us to get into
the rock and roll hall of fame.
Not that,
you know,
necessarily I lost any sleep over it,
but,
um,
validation from critics and people like
that has been something that's been,
you know,
I'm a long time coming,
but it's never been an issue because
our success was based upon people,
you know,
real fans,
the people who buy tickets,
buy albums and stand by you.
Um,
so certainly credibility and,
and,
and the stuff that,
um,
uh,
the media would like to,
to,
um,
dictate is nothing
that we've ever been a part of.
Didn't bother you at all
when you guys weren't,
was it something that
you came to get over,
but it,
did it bother you at all that you guys
weren't getting the record play that or
their radio play rather than
you should have deserved?
I was shocked in the beginning that
some of the critics who made us their
darlings when we were,
uh,
nobody band in New York City,
once we became successful,
even in the earliest days,
we sold out.
Well,
what do you mean we sold out?
You know,
you think I wanted to just be your band.
this one guy with his typewriter.
So,
um,
you know,
we did this to succeed and,
um,
to,
to be slighted for success.
I never got it.
You know,
bands like television or,
you know,
a lot of the bands that came out of
New York that went nowhere went nowhere
because they sucked.
You know,
the critics may have liked him,
but they were,
they were irrelevant today.
And in the scheme of things,
even back then,
they were irrelevant.
It's nice to know that there were a
hipster's even back then when it came to
like liking things that are obscure,
that's always been out.
That's a weird draw,
isn't it?
Well,
you know,
it's not unusual in,
in certain circles that certain people
want to outdo each other by knowing
something more obscure than that.
Oh yeah,
you like that band.
Well,
I know a band that he's in,
he hasn't even sold an album,
you know,
I know abandoned has no
strings on their guitars,
you know,
so it,
it becomes absurd.
It becomes absurd.
Um,
we've been doing this 40 years,
we just did 42 shows in
America to 600,000 people.
So,
um,
the public speaks loudly
and they ultimately,
you know,
dictate what is and what isn't.
That is a,
it's a very obscure,
a very strange instinct to,
to want to find obscure things or more
obscure things that other people somehow
that validates your,
you know,
your,
your um,
street cred.
Yeah.
Your,
your,
your credibility that somehow you,
you,
you know,
something less,
less popular,
less popular.
What's the point?
Well,
your,
your music,
that's what's,
what's crazy is the music
just kept getting better.
And so for anybody saying that
you sold out when the music was,
it was always great but
it kept getting better.
It wasn't like that happens with bands.
Like some bands only have
a few albums in them.
And then for whatever reason,
whether it's the ego divide
between the band members or,
I mean,
what,
what is it you think I love,
I love what I do.
I wake up every day and go,
this is another blessed day,
you know?
And,
um,
that keeps it all fresh.
Um,
I love music.
I love rock and roll.
I Love R and B.
To me,
there's two kinds of music,
good and bad.
Um,
there's so much great music.
There's so much great art.
There's family,
there's so much you know,
to do in your life that,
um,
I love it.
And I don't see any reason to stop,
you know,
I don't see any reason to get old or
stop or I'm having a grand old time.
Well,
we all get old.
There's no way to avoid that,
right?
Yeah.
But you,
you,
you can do it.
You can,
uh,
you can do it gracefully,
gracefully.
But again,
that's up to somebody's
perception of what gracefully is.
You know,
I,
uh,
I have no desire to,
to really get old,
you know.
Um,
um,
you know,
did I ever think I'd
look like this at my age?
No,
but it's cool.
It's good.
You know?
How old are you now?
62.
You look great.
If I look like you had 62,
I'll be happy as fuck.
I'm pretty happy.
I'm happy.
I've,
uh,
you know,
my wife is spectacular.
I've got four great kids.
Um,
life is great.
I make music.
I do the same thing now.
I did in junior high school,
I played the guitar in a rock band.
That's what I do.
I know 62 is like,
people think about like,
Oh,
you're in your retirement years now.
You're not fucking rocking in front of
20,000 people screaming their heads off.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's great.
It's certainly not what
I thought it would be.
Um,
and that's,
that's part of the beauty
is a lot of times your,
your perception of what something will
be like in your life turns out to be
completely false.
What,
what we expect aging to be or what
we expect certain people to be like.
It's all based on preconceived
notions that have no basis in reality.
Yeah.
And this is the first generation really
that seeing rockstars deep into their
sixties just killing it.
You know,
I mean,
we sought of rock and roll as
being a young person's game.
Well,
it was,
it was and with good reason when rock
and roll for started with the exception
of,
of certain artists,
it really was a,
um,
it was a factory for record
companies to create talent.
When you got tired of Fabian,
they gave you Frankie Avalon.
When you got tired of Frankie Avalon,
they gave you,
um,
Jimmy Clanton.
They had all these teen idols and they
just spoonfed you and spoon fed them
songs.
Once you got tired of them,
there was somebody else who came along.
Once band started writing
their own material,
they got the chance to
reflect their point of view.
And as long as it reflected
the fan's point of view,
they could get older.
Rock and roll now has become much
more like the blues because um,
you're constantly writing about your
life and as long as people can relate to
it,
you know,
the day I start writing about,
um,
you know,
the Butler didn't show
today or something like
that,
then you're fucked,
you know.
Yeah.
I saw Tim Allen go on stage once and he
was talking about his Ferrari breaking
down and hung my head.
Yeah,
I'm sure the whole audience is going.
we,
we got one of those too.
Yeah,
he uh,
I guess they forced him to not do standup.
I was doing home improvement
cause he had sort of a risk,
a act and it was like a
very family friendly show.
And then when he stopped doing it,
he came back and when he came back,
you know,
he's got his perspective
is just so skewed.
He's this multimillionaire,
a hugely famous guy and you know,
what does he,
what is he going to write about?
He writes about his fucking Ferrari.
Break it down.
But you don't have to.
No you don't.
No,
I really don't.
I never became famous to cut myself
off from the people who made me famous.
I never,
it was,
it was an escape for me.
I wanted to,
as an escape from a nine to five job,
but I never did it because I
wanted to get away from life.
You know,
you know,
if you go to the supermarket,
I'm there pushing a cart.
You know,
if you go to my kid's school,
I'm,
they're dropping them off.
You don't have a bunch of
dudes earpieces circling you,
scanning the aisles,
the cereal aisle,
if stuff is so pathetic and it's born
out of a bunch of spineless artists who
need to be propped up by people around
them who make them feel important.
The only reason you need all those body
guards around you is because you got a
lot of bodyguards around you.
If you just went about your business,
we would give a shit.
But what if he like Justin Bieber
or what do you think about that?
What about it faster,
you know?
Um,
I mean,
he's essentially,
what you were talking about before
with are the people that the studio is
create.
They write the songs farm,
they put these artists,
they prop them up,
they put them into position.
But now here he is,
this 20 year old boy trying to
manage essentially unmanageable fame.
Yeah.
But it starts with your family
and it starts with your parents.
And um,
if your parents aren't there to give
you a foundation and to be there to tell
you when you're going off the rails,
then you were in a lot of trouble.
So I really,
uh,
when I see a kid in trouble,
I look at the parents.
Yeah.
Well that's good point.
I've met his dad,
let's see.
It seems like a nice fellow but also
seems like it could be one of my friends.
Um,
when you see a young guy like that,
like a young 20 year old guy who's just
ridiculously famous and you think about
your life and your career,
you guys did it in a very unusual way.
And one of the things that was very
unusual is that you have wore makeup and
that was a such a slick move.
Cause you guys were famous as shit
and no one knew what you looked like.
And that's a double edged sword too
because on one hand I kind of craved the
recognition that that guy,
the star child was getting,
but I wasn't getting,
when you can go to a newsstand and every
magazine has your photo on the cover
and you're standing there
and nobody knows who you are,
they just going,
who's the tall guy with the,
the high heels on?
So,
um,
it was,
uh,
but you know it all,
all the time.
It's always going to come down to,
at the end of the day,
you gotta face yourself and do you like
who you are and are you a good person in
or you're living a good life and,
uh,
where are you falling prey to?
Like having salaried friends
around you and will see a posse,
you know,
all,
I didn't want to posse.
I wanted a pussy.
Now,
did you ever,
during this time where you're
sort of craving recognition,
where you guys who are
massively successful on the
cover of all these magazines,
did you ever want to just put the star
child outfit on and just walk around with
no makeup on and go,
Hey,
look at this magazine?
Hmm,
who's this guy looked like it was,
uh,
you know,
it was difficult at times to like want
to be in the audience at these award
shows.
I mean,
I was like everybody else,
you want to,
um,
you know,
Hobnob with all these people and,
and we didn't go out or be seen publicly,
you know,
without the makeup.
So it was,
it was an interesting,
it was an interesting dichotomy.
We can say,
well,
the very few people have
ever had that moment.
I mean,
I don't think anybody could,
like someone could show
Justin Bieber like you could,
you could bring him to someone else
who had been famous very young and they
could perhaps give him some advice,
but nobody could really
give you guys advice.
There was nobody that was a gigantic
international superstar who is essentially
unrecognizable without makeup
on Clark Kent and Bruce Wayne.
They could,
oh,
that's a fucking ridiculous trick.
Clark Kent with his fucking glasses that
great and in a heartbeat isn't a isn't
it great?
You,
you know,
you take off the glasses and it's like,
I don't know who this guy is,
you know?
Yeah.
It was ridiculous.
I mean,
even Bruce Wayne,
I'll,
you could see the bottom of his face.
You got to know who the fuck that guy is.
Pay His friends are
going to go do you your,
your mouth looks a lot
like Batman's house.
That's the beauty of,
you know,
fantasy and comic books.
Yes.
The beauty of fantasy and conquest,
but we just kind of merge those worlds.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you know,
we,
we really have created these
iconic figures in these,
these personalities that exist with
us and without us and will continue to
exist,
whether it's comic books or,
um,
you know,
merchandise,
um,
movies at some point.
All kinds of things.
So it's,
it's really interesting.
We,
we created alter egos that are ultimately
much bigger than we are and much more
timeless than we are.
You're your movie that you guys made,
we,
you were essentially superheroes in a
movie with a Phantom of the paradise I
would is called and no,
that was that.
No,
Phantom of the paradise.
What was that?
That was Paul William,
right?
That was the movie.
I don't know if that was any better.
What was,
what was the,
like the Phantom or kiss me.
It's the fandom of the park.
If I still have no idea what that film,
the end of the film,
I have no idea what it was about.
Um,
that was,
uh,
a real debacle,
a real disaster.
We,
we,
um,
there've been some
pitfalls a along the way.
And,
and uh,
at some point our manager said,
you know,
we should do a film.
And I was like,
okay.
Nobody ever said to us,
you don't know how to act.
You,
you know,
you,
you should take some acting lessons
and you might want to read the script.
So,
um,
as soon as we started work on it,
I remember just going,
this sucks.
This is really bad.
And uh,
they would go,
no,
this is like a hard day's
night meets star wars.
And I bought it,
I bought it.
And I remember going over to bill a coin,
our manager after one of the tanks
and going to this really is horrible.
It's going,
no,
it's going to be great.
Well it's socked.
I mean a movie for TV,
right?
Yes.
But it actually played
internationally in theaters and um,
if you think the effects were
bad on a television screen,
you should see them blown up.
I mean,
I had to go to a screening of it,
um,
before it was shown on NBC and it
was on a big screen at the screen,
a screen actors guild and you know,
we're all going to concentrate in this
box goes up in the air and you see the
wires pulling it up,
you know.
But look,
you know,
this has been a great journey.
This is,
this is that nobody could,
could make this stuff up.
No,
nobody couldn't make this stuff up.
But the,
the,
the path that you guys took really was
a path that nobody had taken before.
I mean,
you guys would go out in public,
he would wear like bandit masks and stuff.
You'd have like Bandanas on your face.
People were trying desperately
to take your photos different,
different time.
Um,
now you have,
you know,
Paparazzi are a breed at this
point where as back then,
um,
literally you could have somebody take
your photo and we would have guys run
over and pull the film.
You can't do that kind of stuff now.
It was,
it was,
um,
uncharted territory,
I guess at that point.
So now everyone's got a
camera on their phone.
It's way more bizarre.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
you have people downloading photos of,
celebs,
you know,
without their clothes.
And I mean,
it's a very,
very technology as,
as tainted a whole lot of things.
As much as it's helped.
Well,
it's just made the world very strange.
It has.
What is the difference between
being famous then and famous now?
How much of a contrast as it,
um,
big contrast,
you know?
Yeah.
It's probably the difference between
what it was like to be president 50,
60,
70 years ago and today,
um,
the,
the kind of scandals that Clinton or,
or some of the other politicians have had,
all that stuff was still going on back,
you know,
in the time of FDR or Kennedy.
But it was just a,
it wasn't public knowledge.
It wasn't,
um,
you didn't see somebody,
somebody didn't walk out of a hotel
bedroom with somebody else and have their
picture taken and all of a sudden it was,
it was all
over the media.
So things have changed.
Um,
if you don't want people
to know something,
don't do it.
That's the only way.
Now,
that's the only way.
There are no secrets there are undone
because if there's you and somebody else,
they know.
Is that good or is that bad?
Um,
I,
I don't know.
It depends on how much
bad stuff you're doing.
Well,
it's a,
I don't even know if he
could say bad or good,
but it seems like there's a lot of
people that embrace it and exploit it.
Like,
do you remember for a long time it was
like for a year or so women were getting
accidentally photographed
with no panties on,
getting out of cars.
And it was pretty obvious by the,
it just the angle of the photograph.
Like how the fuck do you not know?
There's a camera down there from
guys looked down on his knees.
Yeah.
I'm not even on his knees.
I mean he's spread out on his stomach
with the camera up your dress.
You know,
they had to have known,
I mean it was like Paris Hilton
and a lot of these girls,
and I have to say that there are people
now who know how to manipulate and use
the media to their advantage.
Some people can become famous
for doing a porn film with some,
you know,
and leaking a film with them.
And,
and uh,
her name is Kim Kardashian.
You can call her my name man.
Really?
Yeah.
You don't have to,
you don't have to beat around the bush,
so to speak.
I don't think she has a Bush.
That's also what's changed
between then and now.
They're gone.
Yeah.
Porn one when it came to the aesthetic.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But,
um,
where are we going with this?
Well,
we're not going anywhere,
but do you do,
could you,
uh,
when you,
when you see this day and age,
could you imagine if kiss
has started off today,
how different things we'd be fucked.
I mean,
in plain English because the music
industry as it exists today is not even an
industry.
It's just shambles.
And now artists are in a position to have,
to take what the public,
so to speak,
is willing to give them.
In other words,
with the,
this,
um,
onset of file sharing or file sharing
is just a fancy way of saying stealing.
You can't share what you don't own.
The idea that somebody is taking songs
or music off the Internet and taking it
for free and calling it file sharing,
it's like me saying,
um,
uh,
transportation,
borrowing and I steal your car.
You know,
it's,
is it though?
Because if you steal my car,
I don't have a car anymore.
But if you walk up to my car,
make a copy of it and drive it
off and I paid him in the car,
but you didn't,
it doesn't,
it doesn't work like that.
And when people create art with the
hope of being not only accepted,
but also being rewarded so that they can
pay their rent and send their kids to
school and things like that.
And that doesn't happen.
That's,
that's what's stealing does.
But the person who,
who steals on the Internet somehow doesn't
feel the same as going into a store
and stealing a w a cassette,
which don't,
don't even exist anymore.
But if you go into a story,
if you're going to Barnes and noble
or someplace and steal a book that's
blatantly and very clearly illegal,
downloading something,
somehow skirts be the ethical and
moral question of taking something that
doesn't belong to you and
not paying the person for it.
Look,
for me,
it's a,
it's a question more about morality.
In my case,
it's not going to change my life any,
but it sure bothers me that somebody
is taking what they don't own.
And it bothers me that somebody who's
trying to succeed now and starting off
doesn't have a a chance in
hell more than likely have of,
uh,
ever getting that pot of gold,
you know,
but they get the pot of
gold in a different way.
They get it through live performances
so that they're not getting it through
themselves.
Yeah.
But,
but that shouldn't be dictated to by the,
by the circumstances.
That should be a choice.
The idea while you're still getting it.
Well,
who are you to decide where I get my
money while you're still getting it over
there,
but since when do you have
jurisdiction over my revenue?
So I completely see your point and
I agree with you and a lot of ways,
but I think that the reality of the times
we're living in like the digital world
that we're living in property is just,
it's a very,
it's a weird term when you,
when you talk about like digital property,
like digital properties things down.
So that's,
that's true.
And that's a problem,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't change the truth.
And the truth is that what you don't own,
you can't take for free.
You can,
but it's wrong.
It's morally wrong.
It's ethically wrong.
And it hurts.
People did,
when the whole Napster controversy
was coming out to Mars,
all rich was the public whipping boy.
When he came out,
the,
the Lars Ulrich from
Metallica came out and he was,
you know,
saying,
hey,
you guys are stealing.
We're going to take you to court.
His is all theft.
The backlash was tremendous.
I mean,
he was thought of as persona non grata.
people went after that
guy with a vengeance.
A lot of artists sat back and waited
to see how the dust settled on that.
Well,
a lot of artists are wondering
where their royalties are now.
You can't put milk back
in a bottle spilled milk.
And unfortunately things
transpired that there's really no,
no getting around at this point.
Um,
so was Lara's Adeline?
No,
he,
he was just saying I should be paid.
Has nothing to do with
whether he's wealthy or not.
Who are you to dictate that he has enough?
I,
I agree with you,
but I think the way people were looking
at it that didn't have a vested interest
in it,
the way they were looking at it is it's
very obvious that the reality of the
world that we're living in is changing
radically as far as access to information
and songs have become information once
they became digitized and it came ones
and Zeros.
I agree.
You know,
I'm not,
not diminishing it in any way,
shape or form,
but that art becomes information when
it becomes ones and Zeros and ones ones
and zero's go online,
they go online.
I mean there's,
it's,
it's almost impossible to stem the
tide and we see a guy like Lars Ulrich
stepping out there in the early days when
people may be thought that there was a
way to put a,
a stop to this when people didn't tow.
Napster was like the first thing people
didn't really understand bit torrent.
They didn't understand a lot of the
other possibilities when it comes to
downloading,
sharing media.
But now it seems inevitable.
Is there a way to sort
of meet in the middle?
Like I've always had this attitude where
if someone sends me something or a,
you know,
someone sends me a youtube link to a song,
if I like it,
I immediately buy the album immediately.
I go to Itunes,
I buy it right then and there,
even if I'm not planning on
listening to it right now,
out of respect for the artists
song that I'm curious to hear that
I haven't heard in a long time.
I buy it.
But what if someone
sends you a youtube clip?
Is that okay?
Give me the shitty quality.
You're listening to it on an iPhone
or on a laptop or something like that.
Look,
this is,
there's a can of worms open here and I,
I really don't know what the answer is,
but I do know that technology does
not take the place of morality.
I'm not arguing you there.
You were saying is it possible
to incorporate the both of them?
Well,
you were saying is it possible to
meet in the middle and I would say,
why do I have to meet you in the middle?
Why do I have to compromise?
Because of circumstance.
You should,
you should respect my integrity and
you should respect my art instead of me
going,
all right while you got me.
So I'll take 50 cents on the dollar
instead of you giving me the dollar my
wrong.
It's wrong.
I see what you're saying.
But like if someone sends
you a link and says,
Hey Paul,
there's this fantastic band,
you got to listen to this
and it's a youtube link.
Do you just not click it?
No,
I,
I'll,
I'll certainly watch it.
How was that different than
like listened to the radio?
I mean a lot of people found out about it.
You guys from listening to a song on the
radio and then they went out and bought
it.
Is it the immediate access as opposed
to something being broadcast and on the
terms of the radio provider air?
I,
I'm,
I'm not sure.
I would say that whenever
money is changing hands,
the artist should be a part of that.
So if,
if commercials are being showed
on Youtube and revenue is being,
if there's a stream,
then the artist should be sharing in that?
Um,
it's an interesting question because
if I saw a band on television,
hopefully it,
I would see somebody and go,
Gee,
I want to go buy their album
and I would go buy their albums.
So it's a,
it's a selling tool,
but whenever money is generated either,
um,
firsthand or secondhand and
there's an artist's involve,
the artist should be
compensated a unquestionably.
But do you feel that there's a difference
between someone who sounded like
pirate copies?
Like I used to always feel
real uncomfortable with
that when I'm being in New
York and they would sell these
pirate copies of VHS tapes.
Remember those?
Or,
or,
or even cds when they first
figured out CD burners,
people would sell like pirate
copies and I go boys that wrong.
Yeah,
that's wrong.
That's everyone profiting though,
right?
Well,
sure.
Well isn't youtube pro profiting?
Uh,
yeah.
Maybe they are.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure they are.
Um,
but dip file sharing,
they're not right.
We'll file sharing that.
You know,
we go back to that people,
people sharing
artistic material,
sharing anything that should
be paid for under some,
you know,
technical guys were
jargon is it's just wrong.
Is there a way though to
reconcile with the times?
I mean it's,
it's not going to change.
File sharing is going to exist.
Was it,
was it Tom York in his band?
Um,
that didn't they do an album where they,
they offered it on the Internet and said,
just pay what,
what you would like for Paul.
They got nothing.
That's a Radiohead do that.
Yeah,
it was Radiohead.
Yeah.
So they did it.
You know how much he got?
Nothing.
Didn't they get anything?
I think you made some money off of that.
Find out.
Oh look.
Yeah.
Look and see what,
what it averaged per album.
That's a total hippie move,
right?
Pay What you want,
man.
Yeah.
The total of the total stupid move.
I should know this.
I don't think they'll do that again.
You don't think so?
No.
I'll see you.
Most of these are high enough.
They might.
Yup.
Most of the time.
The guy who wants to share the
most has the least to share.
It's true.
That is so true.
Yeah,
that's very true.
I used to work out this yoga studio and
it was a super hippie yoga place and
these,
to have a basket,
you just pay whatever you want.
And I watched ladies pull up in the range
rover workout and not put nothing in
that basket.
He said,
drive me crazy to drive me fucking crazy.
I'm like,
you just pulled up in a range rover.
You walked in,
you did the yoga class
and you just laughed,
you know?
But I come from a a
different point of view.
Well,
I say to people as far as
charities or anything else,
you don't give until it hurts.
You give until it feels good.
You know what,
you,
you know what's in your pocket and
you know what's in your bank account.
And that's how you should give.
You should give knowing what you can
give as opposed to the idea that you give
grudgingly.
I agree 100% but do you see
a possible point of view,
and I'm playing devil's advocate here.
Um,
you see a possible point of view for
a young poor kid who doesn't have any
money,
who's a huge kiss fan who just,
you know,
wants to be able to listen to your
music and just can't afford it,
can't afford to buy it.
And so he downloads a copy
cause he stealing.
Sure.
Of course he's stealing what
the circumstances don't change.
Don't change morality.
Circumstances don't change
what's ethically right and wrong.
If,
if there was no internet,
would it be okay cause he really loves
kist to go into a record store back then
and and steal a record.
Hell No.
Right.
I agreed.
But isn't it different where it's a
physical copy that someone had to actually
print up?
I mean obviously your art created,
it took a long time and a lot of effort
and work and creativity doesn't really
matter if it's on vinyl or,
or if it's access through a computer.
The only difference is that if
someone's accessing it to a computer,
I could send you a copy of something
and it just takes five seconds.
I say,
I hear you have a copy of this.
So one,
but it doesn't,
nobody loses.
What I'm saying is,
of course we do.
We do.
If you were actually going to buy it,
if you're going to buy it,
I'm like,
Paul,
save your millions.
I'm going to give you this copy for free.
Well then you know then maybe,
but if you weren't going to buy it
anyway and someone just gives it to you,
is it in pot?
I mean that's one of the points of view
that people have today is that if you
weren't going to,
if I wasn't going to
buy a particular album,
we're going back to records or
cassettes and you gave it to me.
You already paid for it.
So absolutely.
So if you pay for something
and then give it to me,
okay,
maybe,
maybe there's a,
there's a point there,
but the idea that you took something
for free and gave it to me.
No.
Well if I took something that I paid
for it and made a copy of it though,
perhaps if it was one,
you know,
we were splitting split,
we're splitting hairs,
but I completely respect your opinion
and I complete respect your point of view
and mind you,
it doesn't change my life one bit.
I think it's ethically and morally wrong,
but my concern more is for somebody
who's up and coming or somebody who says,
you know,
I'm just doing this for the art of it.
Well that's okay.
You don't need money.
Money may not matter to
you until you need money.
You know?
Um,
I,
I've known people who've said,
you know,
I'm just doing this because I love
doing it and I'm money's not important.
Well that's because your bills are still
paid when the bill stop being paid,
money's going to be real important.
Yeah,
I'm home.
People always say money
doesn't buy you happiness.
You're absolutely,
totally correct.
But being broke as fuck will make you sad.
That's true too.
And you can't afford food and
you have no place to live.
That makes you sad if
you are broke as fuck.
And then money comes along,
you will be happier because you will have
food and you'll have a place to sleep.
Well you,
you certainly won't,
you certainly won't.
Um,
saddle your unhappiness on the
fact that you don't have food.
The great thing about having money and
success I found is that you stop putting
the onus on things that have no
relevance to ultimately to your
happiness or your state of mind.
In other words,
the idea that I'm not unhappy because the,
I don't have money to pay the bills.
I can pay the bills now and I'm
still unhappy what's going wrong.
So I think that the great thing
about becoming successful hopefully,
and sometimes it's people's
downfall and that's why,
you know,
people wind up with a shotgun in their
mouth or a needle in their arm is because
they think that success is going to
buy them happiness and they wind up
miserable.
And then you have to,
you know,
you have your come to Jesus
moment when you get you,
you decide,
okay,
what now you either you either
spend a whole lot of money on a,
on psychiatry or therapy or
you start numbing yourself.
Yeah.
What I've found is the,
the moment I started making money,
what happened was all of a sudden I felt
a weight lifted off of me where most of
my life I was day to day bill to bill
worrying about how I'm gonna pay this.
How am I going to,
you know,
pay my rent,
put gas in my car.
And then when I started making money,
all of a sudden that went away.
You know,
I wasn't rich by any
stretch of the imagination,
but I knew that I could pay
my bills and I was like,
Whoa,
that's a huge relief that most people
really never get to experience in their
life.
Well also people tend to go,
if I had this,
I would be happy.
The great thing about having that is
finding out whether or not you're,
you truly are happy.
And,
um,
you know,
in my case,
I was still pretty miserable.
And that was really,
that's really what my book is about.
You know,
I had a New York Times
number two bestseller and,
uh,
the book is now in Swedish,
Japanese,
German,
Italian,
Portuguese,
Spanish,
and on and on.
And really,
you know,
I was born deaf on one
side without a righty or,
and,
uh,
in a family that wasn't very supportive.
And,
um,
I thought that success was going to be
the key to contentment and happiness.
And like a lot of other people thankfully
became successful only to find out
that it didn't change anything.
And then the struggle becomes,
okay,
what's it going to take to be happy?
Isn't it fascinating that a lot of people
that become really successful become
really successful because of a whole?
Absolutely.
Look that it takes a person with a,
a plethora,
a vast amount of insecurity to be
comfortable in front of a crowd.
The fact that you want to get up in
front of a crowd and get approval from a,
uh,
a mass of people only says,
I mean,
it speaks volumes about your lack of,
of um,
self confidence.
So just the fact that you want to
be an entertainer or a comedian,
whatever it is,
and being in the limelight means
that you're seeking approval that,
that you innately don't have
a disproportionate amount of
need for when it comes to attention when
it comes to love usually corresponds to
a lack of that same child to Lilly or
adulthood.
You're satiating that need as an
adult that probably was born out of,
uh,
your childhood.
But at that point you can say,
well,
I can get this fixed every night
by going in front of an audience,
which is only temporary,
or let's,
let's do some digging and figure
out what's really wrong here.
And that will only enhance the
performance and everything else.
It won't take the place of it.
It will embellish it
you,
so you changed your motivation,
your motivation became
instead of just get love,
just get all this love and get all
this fame and then I'll feel happy,
then it becomes what then it'd be,
well,
you know,
the fact that there's all these people
who drop like flies from all kinds of
addictions is just proof.
You know,
that,
that people can be famous and miserable
and it doesn't really satiate what's
wrong inside you.
So,
but it fame gives you an amazing
opportunity to go out there and seek help.
And um,
you know,
when I was in my teens,
I walked into a Mount
Sinai hospital in New York,
went into the psychiatry,
a division when I need some help.
When you were in your team.
Yeah.
So it was before you were even famous.
Sure,
sure.
Um,
I've always been a survivor
and somebody who wanted to,
um,
not only succeed,
not only survive,
but thrive.
So I found myself realizing that if
I kept on the path that my parents,
um,
were the role model for,
I was going to be in a
whole lot of trouble.
I want it to become successful.
I loved music.
Um,
I certainly craved adulation,
but I also knew that it wasn't,
it wasn't really what was
going to make me happy.
It wasn't going to make me content.
It's fascinating that you had the
insight when you were just a teenager to
realize that this is a path
that's going to lead to doom.
[inaudible] I think.
I think a lot of people,
um,
maybe brush that aside and
actually have that within them.
I think instinctively,
um,
we're animals and we sense danger and we,
we,
we know more than we think we know.
And then then we intellectualize too much.
What was it that pushed you to
actually go to a hospital and talk to a
psychiatrist?
Um,
my sister had a friend who was getting
this outpatient therapy at Mount Sinai
hospital and it was like,
I heard and I went,
really?
You pay $3 and you,
you,
you see somebody and you talk.
And I had no idea what they were.
[inaudible] was all,
I thought.
Somebody sits in a room and
tells you how to live your life.
And,
uh,
I took us a bus to the subway,
took a few subways and walked in there.
And,
uh,
I knew I needed more than what I had,
although I didn't know
what it was that I needed.
But you know,
that that was part of the,
the,
the search.
So is that what you would call depression?
I mean,
[inaudible] you know,
being born with any kind of difference,
any kind of facial difference,
deformity or whatever
makes you incredibly,
not only vulnerable,
but you're,
you're exposed to a point
of never being able to hide.
If you put on some
ridiculous shirt with a,
uh,
a monkey holding dumbbells
or something else.
Yeah.
Kettlebells,
um,
if you put on a shirt that's,
everybody starts laughing at you,
go home and change.
But if you have a facial difference or
you have something that sets you apart,
you can never go home and change.
So the scrutiny that you're,
you're under his is unbearable.
So that's something I went
through from the time I was
preschool.
And,
um,
you've started to build up to fences and
at some point you don't even know who
you once were.
Um,
so that's what it was all born out of.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not the person who
lives with a two thing.
I'm the person who goes
and gets the root canal.
You know,
I,
I don't want to suffer.
I want to,
I want to dig and go
through whatever ugly and,
and work it out.
And,
you know,
that's really what my whole
life's been been about.
Um,
I couldn't have written my book if I'm
still in the midst of that depression and
insecurity and unhappiness
and unfulfilled.
Well,
I don't want anybody to feel sorry for me.
I've had no,
you just being honest.
I've had spectacular women.
You know,
I've had,
I've had more great
times than anybody could,
could ever imagine.
They would transitory,
but they were spectacular.
Um,
but happiness ultimately comes
from the most simple things,
interaction with people,
great friends,
family and inner contentment.
Um,
when you step off the stage,
you leave that crowd.
They would look,
I did shows in Madison Square Garden and
you may have been at one of them where
I would walk off stage after eight,
18,000 people went crazy and I went to
a deli by myself and when nobody would
fucking believe I'm here by myself
and I just stepped off the stage.
So there's a,
there's a,
uh,
a huge chasm between who you are in the
public and who you are off stage and the
person offstage is the
person you have to live with.
And managing that bizarre dichotomy,
this input
must be very strange to oh,
it's going from one to the other.
Yeah,
I mean credible extremes.
It's a huge struggle and it takes a lot
of people down and no one could tell you
how to do it either.
No one else knows.
No Paul,
you're going to be fine.
Like fuck,
are you talking about?
And it's the same thing.
I can't give anybody advice.
I can,
I can tell you what I did,
but that is going to work for
you is beyond presumptuous.
It's idiotic for me to,
I never,
I never spent a a day a week later.
I have never spend a minute in your shoes.
I have no idea what your life is like.
So,
um,
my advice,
I can't say do it this way.
You have to figure it out.
Well,
I think better than advice,
what you've done is in
your book explaining with
extreme honesty how you felt
about those situations,
how you felt as a young man
growing up with this situation,
with your ear,
be you,
you give people insight into someone who,
you know,
a lot of people look
at you and they'll go,
this guy's not really,
never had a hard day in his life.
He's fucking Paul Stanley,
man.
Like,
look at him up there.
I mean,
come on.
How was that?
How was it?
Oh,
he's the lead singer of fucking kiss.
Come on and loved me and yeah,
and the great thing down,
come on man.
How could,
how could you be sad?
How could it be bad?
But how,
how great a feeling to
be able to say to people,
you know,
something,
I'm not that different than you are,
but you're not.
You really aren't an I'm really not.
That is the key.
Right?
I think so.
I think,
um,
I think separating yourself from people
or not sharing with them how much you
are like them does a disservice to both,
you know,
look,
I make the analogy,
you know,
you can live your life like that.
It protects,
it protects you,
but you get nothing.
You know,
you,
you can hit people and push them away,
but it's not until you're willing to open
up your hand giving it becomes its own
reward whether you're
giving to people with,
um,
support or inspiration.
Are you giving people monetarily,
um,
charity or charitable spirit is
ultimately the most rewarding?
You know,
one of the most rewarding things
I've ever been able to experience is,
is giving and helping others
giving until it feels good.
Yeah.
Like you said.
I,
I agree with that.
I think being generous is a very
underrated activity and until you do it,
and quite honestly,
when,
when it was explained to me,
it seemed ridiculous,
but when you stop judging
other people and you accept,
look,
it's very easy to look at some guy
panhandling on the street and say,
why don't you go get a job?
You have no idea what that person is
living or what nightmare he goes through.
Or she goes through every day would
giving them some money or giving them some
food.
Really Change
Your Life.
Any,
maybe it'll,
it'll help them,
but what do you have to lose it?
It should feel good to do that instead
of kicking somebody who's down.
It's a small person who tries to
make someone else feel smaller.
Well,
you've done a great job in your book of
being a vulnerable and very open and in
a way that a lot of people fail
when it comes to autobiographies.
Autobiographies are very tricky animals.
George Orwell said that the autobiography
is the most outrageous form of fiction
and,
and that's probably why I never wanted
to write one because to just bolster
yourself up or to have bragging rights
about something that may not have even
happened is pointless for me.
The epiphany came when I realized that
I could write a book that my children
would benefit from when
they were old enough.
I have a 20 year old and a three year old,
so
my 20 year olds read it.
And I,
I think it's important for when you're
successful for your children to know what
it took for you to become successful and
that it perhaps wasn't as easy and that
the road wasn't as smooth.
Um,
so my whole reason to ride
my story started there,
but then it started to snow ball in
the sense that I began to realize that
there's a lot of people out there who
could use some inspiration and also some
insight because we all tend to think of
ourselves as singular and nobodies like
us.
Boy,
I'm fucked up and nobody else,
you know,
goes through this.
And when somebody else says,
Hey,
I'm afraid of this or I'm afraid of that.
Oh you are too.
We,
we feel much more secure and bonded
when we share what we have in common.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
Without a doubt.
And I think that you,
like I said,
I think you've done a great service by
being so open in a very difficult way.
And it's very rare for rock stars
especially to open themselves up and be
vulnerable.
If they do,
it's always about some shit.
They don't do any more like,
oh,
I was doing fucking
heroin and I was shooting.
I was like,
yeah,
fuck on stage.
But I'm done with that now I'm all
been clean for a couple hours and uh,
I wrote a book,
look,
everybody has their path and,
and I would never trivialize,
um,
addiction because addiction
is well documented.
It's a,
you know,
a disease that some of
us are predisposed to.
And those are those people I say,
look,
if you are predisposed to that
and if it runs in your family,
get help before you get into the drugs
are before you get into the alcohol.
If you feel that urge much better to
start controlling it before you immerse
yourself in it.
Um,
you know,
look,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm a rock star.
I'm a musician,
whatever you want to call it.
But I'm a person.
I'm a dad.
I'm a husband,
so I don't how I live my life should,
how anybody lives here.
Lives should not be dictated
by their profession.
So whoa,
you know,
this is a great book as rock rockstars.
Don't I go,
you know,
I'm a rockstar maybe two hours
a night when I'm on tour,
yet you have to have a real life,
a complete life.
Otherwise you,
you're shortchanging yourself and
probably shortchanging other people.
But isn't it,
I know a lot of people,
particularly in bands or,
or,
um,
uh,
film actors who don't want to go home.
I get it.
They won't,
don't want to go home
because they have nothing.
They either don't have family or they
don't have something that satisfies them
and makes them feel whole.
And I think what we all are ourselves,
I certainly think so is
to go out and find what,
what you need to feel contentment
without the approval of,
of the masses.
I agree with you wholeheartedly,
but I think that a lot of rock stars,
a lot of actors,
they want to portray an image and
that image is very valuable to them.
They want to what they call protect
their brand and by divulging any past
insecurities or by showing any
chinks in their armor emotionally,
they feel like,
you know,
somehow or another this will be either
used against them or it'll diminish the
publish.
The wizard of Oz
was perception becomes reality.
Yes.
And if you put something
out there and people buy it,
that's who you are.
However,
the,
the problem with it is that other people
will see you as what you've put out
there,
but you know,
you're not,
that's,
that's a real heavy cross to bear in a,
you know,
to,
to accomplish what you set out for
and have the public perceive you to be
something amazing and
still you feel like crap.
I recommend figuring out what you,
what you need to feel good about yourself
because you're going to need that
constant fix of people telling you
you're great and the moment it stops,
you ain't great.
I've never had a problem with depression,
but I'm had a lot of friends who have,
and so I've always
wondered what is the cause,
whether it is a circumstantial,
whether it's the,
the experiences that
they have in their life,
whether it's genetic,
where it's a combination of both.
Um,
for you,
when you started to get over this,
like when you're 19,
how old were you when you went to the,
uh,
I started signer.
I started therapy when I was probably 16.
16.
So he's 16.
He'd go into this doctor's office.
How long was it,
because this is before.
What time when,
how old were you when you guys hit it?
Big.
20.
Let's see.
21,
maybe 22 something.
Goddamn,
that's young.
It is.
She's just,
it's,
uh,
that must have been nuts.
Yeah.
It's like getting the keys to the
candy store and lots of candy,
you know,
was getting the keys
to the fucking factory.
Yes.
Yeah.
To make your own candy.
Make your own candy.
Say Hey,
why don't you put some
more sprinkles in this?
All right Paul,
what do you want?
Sprinkles in the shape of a star.
Let's do it.
Um,
I needed a lifeline and that's
what their puppy was for me.
I don't know that it
changed my life initially,
but it changed.
Look,
if you,
if you go work out,
you know,
when you first start working out,
you don't see results immediately,
but you have the hope and the hope is,
is what drives you is the desire.
And knowing that if I do this,
the end product will be satisfying.
So I booked therapies,
no different therapy,
like everything else that it's
not an immediate gratification or,
or an immediate solution,
but it gives you the,
the,
um,
knowledge that you're on a path.
I'm doing something about this.
Um,
I'm working towards a goal.
I want to lose that stomach.
You know,
I want to do 10 more reps,
whatever it is.
Um,
so that's what it was for me.
And then when the band started and,
and then I stopped for a while and
when the band started to make it,
I called,
uh,
a psychiatrist and said,
I need this ride is about to begin.
And I'm going up on the rollercoaster it,
click,
click and click,
click.
And there's no getting off now
and I need something to hold onto.
What was the general,
what was your main concern?
Um,
just
that,
that's it.
That's a tough one.
Well,
the pitfalls of success and
the vices are all tied up with,
once again,
insecurities.
So either you're numbing yourself
or you're participating in,
in drugs because,
uh,
it's cool.
You know,
there's all kinds of,
um,
there's all kinds of poisons out there.
And,
um,
when they're available,
it's kind of hard to say no.
It's kind of hard to say no.
Um,
I just thought I,
I'd go off the rails a bit,
not a bit.
I thought I was thinking this
is a recipe for disaster.
It's amazing that you had that kind of
insight as a young man experiencing fame,
especially with your background,
your childhood being bullied
and feeling insecure,
and then all of a sudden it's
all coming at and you're like,
Whoa,
I don't think my fucking
surf board this wave.
That's right.
And,
and that's,
that's actually what it was.
It was like,
Whoa,
I am not equipped for this.
You know,
this is,
I this and I've worked
my ass off to get it,
but wow,
now it's in front of me
and that's a big ass wave,
you know?
And uh,
so yeah,
I paddled out against the car and,
and,
uh,
then I had to ride the wave.
I just find it very admirable that you
were able to see that so early and so
young.
That's a very rare quality.
Well,
so I hear,
so you hear,
but that being said,
the,
the great thing is I've
talked to other kids,
I've talked to kids with facial problems,
I've talked to their parents,
and that's something that's Cathartic.
That's something that's great for me
because once I started sharing my issues
and the struggles that I had,
I could see that I was lightening
the load for somebody else.
You know,
it's very easy for parents to say,
Oh,
you're just like everybody else.
I think most of that comes out of guilt.
I think most of that comes out of,
you want to believe that because
you feel terrible for your child,
but your child doesn't need to hear that.
Your child needs to hear.
Yeah,
life is tougher for you.
I'd rather I'll sit
down with a kid and say,
I don't know what you've heard,
but life is tougher for you.
It,
but it can have a happy ending,
but it won't be as easy as it is.
The,
the playing field's not
level for everybody.
And um,
yeah,
yours is going to be a harder path to go.
And I try to sit with parents and say,
listen,
you're,
your kid's not looking
for a solution from you.
When he tells you what's bothering him,
he's looking to be validated.
He just wants to be heard.
And if you minimize what he's saying,
how often you think he's going to talk
to you or she's going to talk to you.
So,
um,
it's a great sense of
satisfaction of,
of being able to go out there and,
and give something,
give something back.
It's,
it's really one of the greatest gifts of
my life is being at a point now where I
can give back and,
and feel like I'm doing something other
than making people happy with music and
make an impact,
not just one on one,
but you could reach millions.
Yeah.
You know,
the,
obviously this book,
you know,
face the music seems to have resonated
with people because it's not being looked
at as a,
another one of those rock
and roll autobiographies,
which honestly really should
be on a roll of tissue paper.
So you could,
you could use it for
something more appropriate.
But,
um,
you know,
it seems to resonate with people and the
word I hear from people is that they're
inspired by it.
And you know,
my,
my journey is not that
different than somebody else's.
And maybe it makes it easier knowing that
somebody who you look up to is on the
same path.
Unquestionably.
It makes it easier.
Did ever go off the rails
at all?
Did you ever have a moment where you
indulged in drugs or alcohol or anything
crazy?
I mean,
I,
drinking was always,
yeah,
yeah.
Life's too short to drink bad wine,
you know.
And,
and one of the great thing is
to be able to afford good wine.
So,
um,
but my early days I drank and uh,
drugs little,
you know,
little dabbling,
but it was different
back then because people,
people didn't see the correlation between
certain drugs and working your way to
other drugs.
Um,
and look,
I saw in my neighborhood,
kids were doing acid and getting,
uh,
you know,
putting the booby hatch,
people are getting committed.
So I said,
okay,
be hatched.
I haven't heard that a long time.
Well,
you know,
I'm a little older than you boobie
boobie hatch in the nuthouse.
Um,
so
I stayed away from,
I even then I said,
well,
acid,
for me that's like a one way trip.
I'm not,
I know I buy that ticket,
I'm not coming back.
So there was certain things I didn't do.
My,
my indulgence was always sex,
you know,
and,
and uh,
that was a good one.
You know,
that,
that was pretty,
pretty awesome.
So how does a psychiatrist
or psychologist,
whichever one it is,
how does someone help a guy like you?
Because I would think that you would
have to have some sort of perspective.
Like if a person is,
if I'd come to a psychiatrist,
say,
Hey man,
I'm an insurance salesman and a,
I don't know what it is,
but I'm miserable.
I can't find any happiness in my life.
And,
uh,
this is what I'm doing.
I'm self sabotaging.
This is what I'm doing wrong.
But when,
when someone comes to a psychiatrist
or a psychologist and says,
Hey,
uh,
I'm,
I'm the lead singer,
one of the biggest fucking
bands in the world,
the hottest band in the world.
You show up,
what,
what are they going to say?
I mean,
what,
what can they tell you?
Hey Yo fucking,
I saw that chick,
you with these hot,
you do a great man.
You are Jesus Christ.
I drove by your house the other day.
Holy the shit.
You live in a castle.
What are you complaining about?
What do you will wiener
him get Outta here?
Honestly,
I think the,
the truth is always the truth.
And,
and um,
the foundation for an insurance salesman
is no different than the foundation for
any rock star or what have you.
I think,
um,
having a,
a strong sense of self and having a,
a good,
a good sense of what
the world is and isn't.
I think a lot of times part of
what makes us feel so endowed is,
um,
our mis conceptions of what other people
are thinking or what other people are
going through.
Again,
it goes back to I'm not normal.
I have all these fears
and doubts and they don't.
So a lot of times I think,
um,
we,
we need to have our,
our,
um,
prospective integrated so
that we understand that
we're not that different than
other people.
And also,
um,
whatever issues we have,
we get to talk about and somebody's kind
of helps us reflect and points us in
the right direction.
The idea,
look,
I went to the,
I w I first walked into a therapist
thinking they were going to say,
okay,
here's what you do and you'll be fine.
And there's none of that.
It's uh,
it's mainly,
I call it the best conversation in town.
You just,
you,
you talk and somebody says,
you know,
throw something back at you and
ask you a question about something.
So it's really you teaching yourself,
but it's not something
you can do on your own.
I mean,
you can't read a self help
book and Change Your Life.
I'm sorry.
Really?
You don't think so except face the music
that can share,
that can change your life.
You don't think that people can read a
self help book and be inspired and may
think you have changed the
direction even slightly.
Yes.
And I think that if anything,
it should make you aware that um,
maybe there's someone out there or some
something out there that can take you
the next step.
I think a book can open your eyes.
I think a book can inspire you.
Um,
but I think
if it's a metaphor for anything else,
I think we all need,
we all need somebody else.
We don't need somebody else's hand.
So when you were 16 and you first
started going to this guy or Gal,
whoever it was,
and you sat down and you
start going over your life,
like what kind of,
how do they,
how do they sort of mold
you into a happier person or
give you the tools to mold
yourself into a happier question?
Um,
I don't really remember.
I think it was more,
like I said before,
it's just a lifeline,
just,
just a dialogue.
Um,
I don't think,
you know,
primal,
primal therapy,
primal scream therapy is a great analogy,
but I think it's all about,
um,
purging.
I think it's all about talking and getting
things out and having somebody help
you to understand or
pose questions to you,
you know,
juxtapose.
Um,
I think it's really about talking
and talking what Freud called it,
the talking cure
in talking,
just the process of going over these
ideas with someone who gives you a
different perspective or gives you a,
you show up every week and,
and it's kind of like,
what did you do this week?
And you can talk about things and,
and um,
talk about relationships or what,
you know,
somebody you're going out with said and
how you responded or what you think.
And somebody could,
you know,
pose a question or ask you,
well,
do you think,
you know,
it's really just,
it's a great conversation where,
where somebody is leading you perhaps,
you know,
to,
to look at things a little
differently and maybe,
maybe a changes the wiring
over a period of time.
Well,
I got to imagine that the wiring gets
screwed up because of negative input.
Totally.
So,
so it's almost like,
I really believe in my case,
in a lot of peoples,
it's like learning to walk again.
You can't run before you walk.
You can't get on with your life
until the basics are in place.
And if the basics were,
um,
miss constructed when you were a child,
an infant,
a toddler,
whatever,
then you can never build a structure.
You've got to go back down and rebuild.
So I think that's,
I think that's what therapy does,
is it,
it,
it doesn't,
it may deal with the,
what is going on in the depression,
but ultimately it's got to get to the
core because you can't change things
unless you change the wiring that I'm
the most simplistic wiring is what's
responsible for what comes later.
Wow,
that's a welcome to psychology today.
It's as important to talk about man,
to say it's very rare that someone ever
gets a chance to hear a guy like you
discuss this stuff so openly and bravely.
And honestly,
I don't think,
you know,
interestingly,
I don't think it's brave.
Um,
you know,
I,
I don't think it's brave because
the people who don't talk about it,
okay.
Haven't come to terms with it and,
and maybe having
rewired fix themselves,
come to grips with things in their life.
To me,
it's,
it's just,
it's reality and there's no
vulnerability attached to it.
I think when you're
still in the midst of it,
you don't want to divulge certain things
because it's not only inappropriate,
but it can come back
to be used against you.
Once you start sharing
your vulnerabilities and
you're still vulnerable,
then people can use them.
I'm really talking about the past.
Um,
and that,
that's,
that's safe and actually in some
ways probably Cathartic therapeutic,
but for somebody to,
to,
it would be inappropriate for
somebody who's got certain
problems,
neuroses,
whatever you want to call them,
for them to divulge them and then
have somebody use them against them.
I'm not in that position anymore.
I'm,
I'm talking about,
I'm talking about a journey that
got me to this place in my life now,
which is a,
a great place.
And I always felt that if
somebody uses them against you,
if you share something with
someone to use it against you,
then you know what kind of person that is.
Right.
But that's a tough lesson
to learn it and you know,
and why put yourself in that position,
you know?
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
Um,
when,
when you started taking
off and you realize like,
okay,
this is all,
we're on the rollercoaster,
click,
click.
Did you start a psychiatrist
on the road?
Oh God,
no,
no.
So how long would you go on the road for?
I was almost always on the road,
so if I was on the road,
um,
maybe once a week I would,
I make a phone call.
I heard somebody saying,
you know,
I was on the phone every day,
or,
but then again,
that person
doesn't remember what they did yesterday,
but,
um,
no,
I mean,
it,
it doesn't need to consume you.
And a therapist is in a span,
golly,
they're not going to,
they're not a puppet master,
but in an inappropriate time in your life,
go as often as you feel you need to.
The issue would be if you
did that your whole life,
that would probably say to me that you're
not making a whole lot of progress.
And I would say a therapist is
no different than anyone else.
Um,
you know,
there's great,
there's brain surgeons is neurosurgeons
and then there's brilliant
neurosurgeons.
And,
um,
but then again,
it's also a matter of what works with you.
Um,
if you have some sort of synchronicity,
simpatico,
whatever you want to call it,
with the,
with somebody,
you'll,
you'll get much farther.
And if you don't find
yourself getting somewhere,
then maybe you need to move on.
I had a very biased idea of therapy
when I was younger because I worked with
actors and there were so self indulgent
when they were talking about the
therapy.
I'm like,
this is just giving you another fucking
opportunity to talk about yourself.
That's what this well,
yeah,
actors are very funny.
And um,
um,
I have to say that at one point in my
life I decided that musicians were just,
a lot of them are very,
very narrow in,
in,
in their,
um,
pursuits outside of music.
And I found that really,
really boring to get together and old
somebody wants to talk about is like
guitars or something.
So I said,
I'm going to hang out with actors.
And I started hanging out.
Uh,
a friend of mine owned a,
a bar in New York and I,
uh,
was there every night and became
friends with a whole lot of people.
And I found out,
my gosh,
these people only want to listen to me
talk so they get their turn and they just
wanted to talk about themselves.
And uh,
that's not,
that's not a generalization.
That's just my experience with,
cause I don't want everybody
calling me up and saying,
you know,
you talking about me.
No,
I'm not talking about you.
But there were,
there are certainly a lot of people in,
uh,
the,
the performance field who
love the spotlight and,
um,
tolerate use speaking so
that they get their chance.
Yeah.
Going from musicians to actors,
looking for depth is like
going from a pool to the ocean,
looking for wet or water.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I remember going to,
um,
going to a party at,
at,
um,
Lee Strasburg's house,
who's arguably like the,
the,
you know,
one of the,
the gurus of,
um,
of method acting and all the famous
people were there and we were all in the
living room and they all seem so unhappy.
Oh.
And it's like I was thinking,
I want to create from joy.
I don't want to create from misery.
And you know,
it's like every,
I wanted to have an umbrella and I wanted
an umbrella because it seemed to be
reigning in this place.
But I know certainly there were a lot
of people in different fields of the art
who feel that their creativity is
based on there being unhappy or,
or they're,
you know,
discontent.
I don't want to paint from there.
I don't want to sing from there.
I think it's a trap.
W We,
we experienced the same
thing with standup comedians.
A lot of standup comedians almost believe
that you have to be miserable outside
of being on stage in order to create and
that your reward for being miserable is
dead when you're killing.
When you're on stage and
everybody dying laughing,
this is,
this is what you get to experience
that other people don't,
so that when you're not doing this you,
you're a miserable fuck.
You're supposed to be
running around frumpy a,
you know better than I do,
but I've certainly met my
share of miserable comedians.
I've met a lot.
I'm better.
I think that's changing a bit.
People are becoming more aware
of the fact that there is no,
there's no individual singular
path to any creative endeavor.
Whether it's music or
whether it's a painting.
He is a lot of different ways to do
it and you could be really good at it
without being miserable.
Yeah,
there,
there were people and I
certainly experienced people
who are afraid to be happy
because it will affect their
creativity and I got to tell you,
you know,
happiness is,
is probably the,
the best additive to creativity.
When I was young,
I,
this is how stupid I was when I
first started doing standup comedy.
I actually stopped meditating
because I was worried.
I was like,
if I become too calm and if I
achieve any sort of enlightenment,
this will fuck up my subject matter.
Because part of being a standup comedian,
it's about kind of being rude or
at least being shocking in a way.
At least I thought that I was like,
I can't be meditating.
I can't be going to yoga.
I gotta I gotta get this out of my head.
Yeah.
But that,
that sharpness and,
and peace of mind and contentment
that can come from yoga therapy,
you know,
a happy home life,
whatever is something that
can really enhance your,
you know,
whatever your creative outlet is.
And uh,
it's just always interesting to see
people who were afraid to be happy.
Yeah.
There's many,
there's many engines of motivation.
They don't always necessarily
have to be negative.
And that's why I was curious about your
approach because you were coming from
this place of,
uh,
of negativity,
but you figured out how to
channel it into applause.
I suspect it,
but what was I singing about?
I was seeing about getting laid.
I was singing about partying
and that was was terrific.
Um,
what was lacking was some of the,
the,
the other,
um,
inner skills.
But,
um,
I,
I sang,
I sang about nobody was interested in me.
What do you want to hear songs
about me being miserable?
I would have the day,
man.
I was having a grand old time and uh,
reveling in,
in,
uh,
in everything I had.
You know,
I grew up wanting a playboy playmate,
you know,
I wanted,
I got all,
you know,
I got all that stuff.
It was,
and it was terrific.
The great thing about having things is
it gives you a chance to see whether you
really want it,
you know,
and that that's,
that's pretty cool.
People spend their lives,
um,
sometimes chasing things
that they never get.
I've been very fortunate.
I've pretty much gotten everything
I chased and some of it,
it was all worth having,
but it wasn't all worth keeping.
So what you thought it would
be before you got there?
Why do I,
sometimes I thought that certain things
would be the solution and all the white
playmate.
Yeah.
I mean it wasn't for Thursday,
it was a solution.
Um,
but,
um,
you know,
look a,
again,
my life's been awesome,
awesome.
And,
um,
it got me to here and,
uh,
you know,
when you hear poor me,
when you hear people talking,
poor me,
it's a lonely and you know,
my life's been great.
Um,
and it's all led me to where I am now.
And,
uh,
I,
I have nothing but great
memories and no regrets.
So you don't have to go
to therapy at all anymore.
You don't do any of that.
I go,
I go sometimes once,
I,
if I can,
I go once a week,
once a week.
Yeah.
As I said to me,
it's not laying on a couch and,
and you know,
trying to,
trying to figure out,
uh,
you know,
minutia.
It's really a great,
if you have a great therapist,
it's great conversation.
Literally,
Hey,
here's what I did.
I did this this week and,
you know,
it's,
um,
I call it life school.
It's just kind of,
you know,
I don't expect somebody else to,
to be able to tell me what,
what the answer is.
They probably don't have
the answer for them.
You know,
when,
when we put therapists or doctors,
when we put anybody on a pedestal
where we're on dangerous ground,
these are just people,
they have their own issues.
They may be great at helping you,
but it doesn't mean that they
have the answer for them.
We're all,
we're all out there trying
to figure it out them to,
yeah.
Even like the Dalai Lama,
the Dalai Lama doesn't have
sex and he only wears orange.
Okay.
Does they have a swollen hand or anything?
Nope.
No.
He believes it's
too complicated that simplify it.
Oh,
come up.
Yeah.
It's much simpler than he thinks.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
I've always found issues with people
that choose this monastic lifestyle.
Seeing that that's like the most,
the,
the most simple path,
but you're missing out on some of the
most beautiful joys of life because you
believe that you can't
handle relationships or he
can't handle being a father,
or you can't handle the pursuit of
art or whatever you're doing what,
you know,
to take the other side of the coin.
Maybe they're right about them,
you know,
it's like when somebody says,
wow,
you know,
so and so's missing out
by not having children.
I go,
not really,
because chances are they wouldn't get
out of it what you're getting out of it.
Right.
So,
you know,
it's very easy to project.
Um,
and it,
it's,
it's called transference.
You know,
it's very easy to,
to imagine your feelings on somebody
else or your life on somebody else.
And it doesn't always,
it doesn't always go that way.
So,
um,
if the Dalai Lama or
anybody else's is happy,
you know,
leading some sort of monastic life or,
or being celibate or whatever,
he thinks he's happy,
he's never been one of them.
Paul Stanley orgies covers gigantic
heart shaped beds and he got 50 tens
swarming Ya.
He doesn't know that.
It's hard.
Yeah.
I had to be you.
He doesn't know what the
fuck he's talking about.
Yeah.
I,
I've always been very conscious about
not projecting that to other people when
it comes to like how much children has
changed me that you need to do it because
I,
I used to resent that when I was
single and people talk to me about,
Oh,
you need to get married and have kids,
but get the fuck outta here.
Like,
Oh man,
kids change.
I'm better because of kids.
Yeah.
You need to have kids and
your life and be like,
you need to fuck off.
You know,
like,
I hate proselytizing.
So when people would do that,
I'm very conscious.
There's nothing worse than a
riff then a reformed hooker,
you know,
or reformed alcoholic.
Yeah.
You know,
those people are brutal
to go about your life and,
and,
and understand and realize that everybody
has their own path and that will work
for you and is working for you may have
absolutely no relevance to their life
whatsoever.
You know,
somebody a couple of days
ago was saying to me,
you know,
against,
oh so and so's there really when
I see people that don't have kids,
I really think they are missing out.
I go,
they may be missing out on nothing because
they're not equipped to have kids or
they wouldn't get what you're getting
out of it or what you're getting out of
your relationship or your marriage.
Some people,
you know,
everybody just needs to
find their own contentment,
whether it's in an orange robe or a
underneath an orange robe with a blonde.
I just think it's hard for some folks
to balance that perspective to say,
you know,
they think of how much they love their
children and how much they love their
family.
They couldn't imagine being without it.
So they see someone,
they said,
well you can't possibly be happy
because you're not living my life.
Well it goes a step further.
I always say to people,
look,
never think that when somebody tells
you something means the same thing as if
you said it.
If somebody says I love you,
don't for a minute think that they
define love the same way you do.
You need to say,
what do you mean?
Because somebody will do
something and you'll go,
I thought you loved me.
And they go,
I do love you.
So you know the I love means
I'm allowed to steal from you.
Exactly.
You know,
file sharing.
Um,
cause it's all,
it's all digital.
It's all zeros.
No,
but it's so easy to,
to,
in relationships you'll hear somebody
say something and you just take for
granted.
Oh they mean they can mean
something totally different.
So it's always a always important
to say to somebody what,
what do you mean?
What does that mean to you?
Yeah.
The context of words,
you know,
just words by themselves,
you really need,
and also everyone has their own sort
of internal definitions of things like
you've,
you have to kind of establish that when
you get to know people and figure out
whether or not you really
want them in your life.
Oh my life became so much simpler
when I cut most people out of it.
I really,
truly,
and I recommend it for everybody.
Toxic people.
There was nobody.
Yeah.
Nobody in my life that is
there because I feel obligated.
Nobody's there because I have to have
a business relationship with them.
There's nobody around me that
I can't look in the eye and go,
I want to be here.
So once you cut all that stuff out,
life becomes much,
much easier,
you know?
Yeah.
And if someone cuts you out,
maybe you need to step back and go,
hey,
what's the,
what did I,
oh,
maybe I'm a Douche.
Maybe we need to look at
myself a little bit better.
This guy,
I decided I was toxic.
Bam.
You know?
Um,
and it's also great to be
with somebody who you respect,
who can tell you when
you're being an idiot,
you know,
huge.
You know,
to be able to take the heads.
Yeah.
They are the greatest advances
often come from the lowest lows.
Like to to realize like,
oh,
okay,
this is a complete failure.
Let's put the pieces back together again
and figure out why I failed and then
move forward.
You can't really relate to that as being
a rock star when you were 21 person
succeeds is the one who
continued after they failed.
Yes.
You know,
and uh,
and maybe adjustments.
Yeah.
Everybody has dealt with failure and the
person who fails ultimately is the one
who didn't continue on.
Well,
that's why it's so a fascinating to me
and admirable that you were able to make
these adjustments very early on.
I certainly started early on and perhaps
if I had known how long would it take
to,
to see those adjustments,
uh,
come to some sort of fruition?
Maybe I would have thought twice about it.
But,
um,
you know,
it goes back to you can't kid yourself.
You can get everybody else
around you and you can say,
I'm okay.
And you know,
you can convince people that
your grade or whatever you want,
but you know the truth
and you have to live with it.
So how did you
make the transition?
Like you,
you were obviously a very content,
very happy person.
Now how long did it take while this
rockstar roller coaster ride was going on
before you really felt
comfortable with it all?
Um,
well,
I,
I was married before and
perhaps what marriage,
like a bad marriage can teach you.
Like anything else in life,
it can teach you what you don't want,
you know?
And,
uh,
um,
I needed to go through a marriage that
wasn't great and got a great son out of
it and,
um,
just continued on the path.
It's kind of like getting
off the wrong exit.
You know,
I saw some,
I saw some very interesting scenery
and then I got back on the freeway.
But,
um,
it's been an,
it's been an ongoing path
and I'd say the last 15,
20 years have been like,
just better and better
and better as I look.
I,
I met White,
my wife that I'm,
I'm with now,
I met Erin 13 years ago
and without hesitation,
the best 13 years of my life,
you know,
just,
uh,
just incredible.
I didn't even know a
relationship like this existed.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
That's a,
that is really the key,
isn't it?
It's like finding someone
who you're compatible with,
finding someone who,
you know,
it just,
just fits.
So may gets thrown around so much
Chyna and it's a,
it's a term that's so abused by,
I certainly use it in the past,
but when you get it right,
it's pretty,
pretty amazing stuff.
I mean,
the,
the peace of mind and the
contentment that you have,
being with the right person is incredible.
I mean,
I know beyond any doubt,
this is where I'll be
poor the rest of my life,
you know,
I hope hers too,
you know?
But I I know from,
from where I'm at,
you know,
I,
I've got four amazing kids and,
and uh,
an incredible wife and everything else is
icing on the cake,
the rollercoaster ride of doing,
you know,
being in a rock and roll band and
being is some international superstars.
Got To make it very difficult to keep a
relationship too because you're always
focused on so many different things.
You've got the songs putting together,
dealing with the inner complications,
have been in the band,
you're touring,
you're putting out albums,
a lot of pressure and stress as well,
right?
Yeah.
But when you,
certainly when I was younger,
nothing warranted.
I had no qualms about,
you know,
um,
my relationships were secondary.
I would tell somebody that,
you know what I mean?
My band comes first.
My music that went over,
well,
you know,
I didn't lose any sleep over it.
Isn't that the thing that
always happens in bands?
Like a girl gets in there
like there's always like the,
uh,
whether it's a lead singer,
a lead guitarist has a wife who,
uh,
all of a sudden steps into the picture
and she starts telling the other guys
they have to shape up or do
this or what a nightmare.
What a nightmare.
That's the Valerie Burton Elliot,
you know,
we,
I,
I can't speak for any other band.
Uh,
but what I've heard from some
other bands were seen as,
you know,
that,
that's,
that's a nightmare.
You know,
look,
we,
we still don't let anybody
into our dressing room
that is sacred ground.
Even,
even wives.
Nope.
That's,
you know,
that is,
that's where we live.
You got to have something that that's,
um,
either sacred or just belongs to the,
to the four of you or the five of you.
So,
you know,
our dressing room,
our kids once in a while might,
might come in,
but everybody knows that's,
that's,
that's not for,
that's not for our families,
but your kids.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
He tell you why tries drop the kids
off and wait for me and on the door I'm
going to show them how to pack.
Yeah.
So,
wow.
It's a weird ride.
I mean,
did no one else has mean unless
you're talking to other rock stars,
no one else has experienced
the life that you've had.
It's true.
It's very true.
I mean,
when,
when you politicians
want to be rock stars,
everybody wants to be a rock rockstar.
Rockstars don't want to be
rockstars want to be rock stars.
The reason everybody wants to be at it's,
it's as good as they say
it.
Trust me,
it,
it's awesome.
You know,
it doesn't have to kill you.
It doesn't have to scar you.
It's awesome.
And you guys had been through the
full spectrum of success 40 years.
Yeah.
I mean,
you were,
you were gigantic with the makeup and
then what made you take the makeup off?
Like what,
what was that about?
Missteps?
You know,
I,
I think that again,
when,
uh,
when we,
we booted Peter out of the band,
um,
we,
we felt that Eric Carr when he
came in and he did another persona.
So we did that.
And,
um,
I think we,
I think between Apathy and laziness
that said in within the band,
we became very,
uh,
fat and rich,
you know,
just,
we forgot why we loved what we did and
became more involved with trying to get a
approval from our peers
or friends or girlfriends.
And then within the band when we
started bringing in new people,
this whole idea of
creating new characters,
I think we lost the plot
and I'm taking off the,
was
like taking a bucket of
cold water in the face.
It was a way for us to,
to regroup.
And as far as I was concerned,
it was a time for us to say,
if we're not valid as a band,
if we're not good enough to be a band,
then we should call it quits.
If we can't exist as a
band without the makeup.
And quite honestly,
people had grown tired of it.
Um,
I think people weren't tired of the music,
but they were listening with their
eyes and didn't want to see us anymore.
They didn't want to see,
um,
perhaps what we'd become.
Um,
so I went,
we need to,
to,
you know,
take,
take this chance to take this leap
of faith and take the makeup off.
And we did.
And,
um,
you can't compete with
those four iconic images,
no matter what you do without it,
it's always going to Pale.
That being said,
we were selling,
we were platinum from liquored up on,
but people talk about it.
Yeah.
You know,
that was like the downtime.
Well in a sense.
Yeah.
Because,
um,
you just,
you,
you pale next to kiss and makeup,
but it,
it,
it got us through.
Um,
let's see.
It was probably 13 years
probably without makeup.
And um,
you know,
we honed our skills and also,
um,
readdressed and recommitted
ourselves to what we once were and,
and worked our way back and um,
sold a lot of albums.
But understandably,
people think of them as the lean years.
Those lean years would
make most bands fat.
Yeah.
We'll look it up.
It's still one of my all time favorites.
But when you guys took the makeup off,
what was that transition like to go from
being a famous person who has an almost
a non famous face to being a famous
person that now everybody's like,
oh,
I loved it.
You know,
I craved it,
you know,
it was awesome.
It was awesome to finally go,
yes,
it's me.
It's me.
Um,
I loved it and it didn't change who I
was on stage at all because I've never
really been playing a part.
Um,
that's why am so whether without makeup,
I'm not looking in a
mirror when I'm on stage,
I'm just being me.
So it didn't change.
It changed.
I'm changed it for some of the other guys,
but,
um,
it gave us look it up.
Heaven's on fire.
A lot of really cool stuff.
Um,
creatures the night war machine.
I love it.
Loud.
A lot of,
well,
no makeup.
Yeah,
that was the last,
yeah,
that was the last gasp.
I wanted that album without makeup.
And we kind of,
you know,
understandably,
Chine was much more reluctant than I was.
So we look it up was we took it off.
So we,
we,
uh,
we were more in touch with ourselves.
So after 13 years,
um,
I remember thinking if we're going to
get back together with the other guys who
I swore I would never do again,
I had,
now's the time because
I don't know if any,
if these guys are going
to live that much longer,
you know,
I don't know.
I just don't know.
I don't know what they've been doing or,
or,
um,
you know,
we're where they've been,
so,
so it's 13 years with no ace,
no,
Peter.
Um,
I think it was,
it was actually longer.
Um,
uh,
Peter was 1979 and ace was 82.
So,
um,
you know,
we reached out to them and went through
a whole lot of song and dance and a
whole lot of dating,
so to speak.
And you know,
um,
ultimately,
uh,
did kiss on plugged and brought them out.
And then after that we,
we did a full scale reunion,
which was enormous.
And,
um,
with two guys who was
so grateful to be back.
You know,
Peter was just a joy.
I'll never do that again.
I,
you know,
I what I did,
uh,
I'm so glad I'm back and
I get a second chance.
And they were both
terrific for about a week.
A week longer than that,
it seems like a week.
It was,
um,
by midway through the reunion tour,
those cracks just started showing again.
And,
and,
um,
the same stuff started happening and uh,
you know,
it w it was impossible.
We did two more tours
after I think we did.
I'm psycho circus and those
guys were barely on the albums.
And then we did,
um,
the farewell tour and the farewell tour.
Honestly,
I think we were so miserable.
Gene and I was so miserable.
We were kind of thrown in the towel.
And then by the end of the tour,
I remember a guy and I figured,
we're,
we're done.
It's over.
I was a,
a car wash and one of the guys says to me,
boy,
I loved,
I loved the farewell tour when you're
doing the 35th anniversary tour.
I went,
you,
you don't want us to be gone.
And I realized that really
what the farewell tour was,
was saying farewell to those guys again.
And I would never give up the makeup
again and I would never give up the band.
The stance of the band has always
been that the band is bigger than the
individuals and to suddenly have people
who were sabotaging and compromising the
band and the fans suddenly in
charge to say the band was over,
was just not going to happen.
So it was a wake up call for me.
So,
um,
since then it's been,
you know,
just really just pretty amazing.
What's the difference between going back
and putting the makeup on once people
already know what your
face looks like and,
you know,
not,
that's a different time in my life.
I'm a different person and
a really terrific to be
able to experience that kind
of phenomenal success at a different point
in my life where I appreciate it in a
different way.
Most people don't get to to do that,
you know,
and to,
to regain the championship and,
and uh,
um,
smell the roses or whatever it,
it when,
when you're a little bit more equipped to,
to appreciate it in a different,
different way to real kiss fans.
When you guys made that reunion tour and
you got back together with Peter Criss
and ace freely,
uh,
Kevin James,
you know Kevin James Sherman,
queens is core body mine.
Huge Fan.
Huge Kiss Fan.
So he and I went together.
We went two nights in a row.
We saw you guys in La and uh,
we just,
we were just going crazy
because it was the whole band.
Everybody was together.
So it was so storybook a me initially.
Yeah.
Did you try to like get
those guys straight?
Did you?
Sure.
But give them some Ibogaine,
take them to the jungle,
you know,
look,
it's like,
um,
I will try to save anybody who was
drowning until they start pulling me under
and I got to cut them loose.
You know,
it,
it was,
it was hopeless and his booze.
Is it drugs?
Is it a combination as a personality?
I think it's just personalities and
everything else exacerbates things,
but it starts with,
with you and who you are.
The rest of it just,
just takes it south.
So,
um,
I just,
you know,
found myself in a position where
the w there was no choice except to,
to change things.
But look,
all I can tell you is the
band has never been better.
Never sounded better,
never been more the band that I want it
to be because there were four people now
who truly love and respect the band and
want to do what's best for the band and
not what's best for them as individuals.
Everybody in the band will
swallow their ego and their pride,
me included,
to do what's best for the band.
And uh,
that's a great,
you know,
we built something great on.
Once again,
it goes back to foundation.
You can't build anything
without a great foundation,
whether it's your personality
and your life or a band.
So we've got a great foundation,
but what we built on it is,
is pretty,
pretty terrific,
pretty tremendous,
probably much more difficult to take
something for granted when you came into
the band as a fan of the band.
Now One guy,
20 years,
one guy,
10 years,
you're talking about
a 40 year plus career.
Yeah.
And,
and honestly,
they are tremendous contributors and,
and great to be around
and we all socialize,
which is something terrific.
The combustibility of that original
band was perhaps what made it in the
beginning,
but made it inevitable
that it would combust.
You know,
it was,
it was so volatile.
I really hoped when we did the reunion
that we could move forward and take the
band and,
uh,
see it to that,
you know,
happily ever after.
But,
um,
you know,
the wizard of Oz,
it's just,
uh,
it's,
it's not,
it's not that.
It's just not that way.
Well,
even at,
you know,
as you described your own life,
you're,
the change of your perception
of the world was a slow,
gradual thing with a conscious effort.
Without that conscious effort
changes virtually impossible.
And these guys just getting this second
chance probably gave them a lot of
enthusiasm and a lot of,
you know,
I'll never do it again
because they recognize like,
wow,
holy shit,
I'm a kiss again.
Here we are,
we're doing it again,
we're back.
But ultimately if you're more concerned
and driven or or or ruined by what
someone else has rather
than what you have,
if you're more concerned with
me making more money than you,
which is just a given because I
never left the band once or twice.
So that became a big issue
once you guys well be,
it's surfaced and it was only one of,
you know,
a lot of issues that that once
again came to the surface.
But that was one that was not negotiable.
And did you think that it could
have possibly even helped?
I mean if you said,
okay,
listen guys,
we're back where the band,
let's go 25% all around.
We,
we,
we that that's a,
that's a movie we already
saw and it didn't work.
You know,
we,
we did that the first time
around and it didn't work.
And here we are 13 or 15 years later,
bringing two guys back in who were
virtually broke and have no career into a
band that is maintained platinum status.
And you don't come in as a,
as a partner in equal.
You come in,
um,
as someone who who is paid and salaried,
now mind you once again,
when,
uh,
rejoining the band is making
you a millionaire again,
I wouldn't,
you know,
I w I wouldn't,
uh,
bring out any hankies
to wipe my tears away.
These,
they did very,
very well,
but they just didn't do as well as
you and Jean and nor should they.
Yeah.
Not sure.
I see your point.
I could see how they get bitter about it,
but,
but once again,
there was more to it than then.
Again,
um,
drugs and sycophantic relationships
and over inflated ideas of,
of who they were and what they could do.
Um,
it's just didn't work.
What seems like with every band,
there's always this ultimate conflict.
And one of the things that you guys
have managed to do is whatever conflicts
that you've had with gene,
he guys have managed to stay together.
Gene and I are,
are,
are so unlike each other.
I mean completely unlike,
you know,
if somebody was just
saying that this morning,
um,
but we're together for
45 years I think now.
That's insane.
Yeah.
That's from when I was two.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
we're together because we have a common
bond and we have something that we
believe in and we have a work
ethic and we put other stuff aside.
I mean,
there's been times,
certainly where we weren't
getting along very well at all or,
or,
um,
not speaking,
but we're in the band together.
So you were not speaking,
but yet you were playing together.
Yeah.
There have been some,
some times of,
um,
some real resentment and real anger.
But,
um,
so what,
I mean,
we're,
we're still here and we do what's
best for the band and always have.
And that's amazing.
And we've never gotten along better as,
that's incredible.
Like how did you guys do that?
When you're performing on stage,
if you weren't speaking to each other,
well I mean more or less
not speaking to each other,
right?
Disliking each other and intensely,
but you get up and that's
where we make magic.
You know,
I said to another band are really,
really big band.
Nickelback no are really,
And um,
I,
you know,
they were complaining about the
relationships within the band and I said,
you know,
you don't have to love
everybody in the office.
And I said,
in your case,
if you can make magic on stage,
anything else is a bonus.
So the fact that you get up there
and are a great band should suffice.
You want more?
Go get a family,
you know?
Um,
the,
the key to a great partnership
is knowing it's limitations.
He should give seminars on
how to keep a band together.
I should give seminars.
Period.
Yeah.
Why don't you give seminars?
I've been asked.
You should really,
you're an inspirational guy.
I mean,
it's not just that you're
an iconic rock figure,
but you're a very down to
earth and very centered.
Very.
Do you meditate at all?
Do you do anything?
No,
just just the therapy and Jim more.
It's just the daily.
Yeah,
it's good to be Paul Stanley and you know,
it's great to work,
work,
work and find yourself at a,
at a great,
you know,
juncture in your life,
enjoying your work,
enjoying we're enjoying
your life and being,
and not,
not using your work as
an escape from your life.
And most of most,
you know,
a lot of performers,
I won't say most,
but a lot of performers use their work
as an escape to get away from a life that
they don't like.
And he gives this something that you
figured out over the years through therapy
and through thinking
and analyzing and yeah,
I mean I,
I can't put everything on therapy,
but I'm innately,
it comes down to once again,
do you like who's who you see
in the mirror and if you don't,
how do you make yourself like that person
and therapy and even pursuing it was
sort of obviously because of that,
because of this,
this,
this thinking.
Yeah,
just going,
well this isn't working.
Maybe somebody else can enlighten
me or direct me on another way.
Did we figure out how
much radium had made?
Uh,
it was arguable they sold around
3 million copies of that album.
Uh,
right.
They also said that three
times that one on bittorrent.
So that did make money.
Um,
whether or not they would
have made 10 times that,
who knows,
why would it be,
I'm a bit torn.
If you could pay whatever you want,
you can pay whatever you want.
But yet they also sold
a special copies of it.
They sold an album version.
They sold a special box version
and 100,000 copies of that.
Right.
And what did it work out to per album?
It didn't,
the information I was finding
didn't say Ppar Alpha.
They kept their mouth shut about it was,
it was a disaster.
As soon as it went on.
Bit Torrent free stopped.
As soon as bit torrent went on,
they were like,
oh,
and I'm more free.
Oh really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When it,
when I bit too aren't they got mad?
Oh wait,
just kidding.
Just kidding.
Dark bags of the world.
You guys are going to
do a residency in Vegas?
We are.
We are at the end of this month.
They are dude,
that's awesome.
I'm going to be watching that.
Great.
Where are you going to be?
What?
What about?
We're at the hard rock in the joint.
We mainly were doing Wednesdays,
Fridays and Saturdays,
although it's switches a bit.
And um,
we're actually,
um,
I think we're 40% above any other band
that's done the done the residency there
with ticket sales writing.
So,
um,
the joints of good venue
that's not too big.
It's intimate.
And what's really interesting is when you,
you play a small place,
you tend to downsize.
We actually are cramming more stuff
in so it's re because we don't have to
travel with it.
So we're really,
oh yeah.
Right.
We're really,
we're really gearing
up for something great.
And at the end of this month,
we do,
um,
the kiss cruise,
which goes out every year and has,
uh,
you know,
about 3,500 fans from 33 countries
around the world get on the ship and,
and spent four days a rocket
in Roland bring other bands.
Wow.
So you hang out with these
freaks for four days.
We don't hang out.
We,
we do.
Um,
we do two shows in a theater and um,
then we,
we go to an island and we do an acoustic
set there and then we have other bands
with us the night before.
We leave port cheap trick
plays and it's great.
So we do that and then we
do the Vegas residency.
Wow.
So you do this,
this,
this tour on this boat and you're
trapped on a boat with all these people.
That doesn't freak you out at all?
Well,
no,
because we have a section
to ourselves where we're,
nobody can come.
And so that's where you got to do to the
ear pieces and then they're on the boat
and the AK seven.
Yeah,
I would think that that would
be the one thing that was like,
I know opie and Anthony
were going to do a,
a a boat tour and I was like,
man,
I have to say the first tee I dreaded,
you know,
I dreaded the idea of him
and I'm four years into it.
I mean,
my family comes,
it's awesome.
Well,
it's gotta be amazing to have
3,500 fans on a boat with you.
Well,
the beautiful thing about it is
that they're from all walks of life.
I mean,
a guide last year was in full gear,
all my full gear and gave me a book.
He was a doctor and he,
he wrote a book on forensic science,
full gear,
meaning he's dressed like you.
Yeah.
That's gonna be weird.
So you have,
you know,
you have gays and straights and you know,
every,
every permutation of,
of,
of life and,
and it's awesome.
Wow.
It's awesome.
That's got to be strange seeing
people dressed as your character.
Well,
it's great when,
when you realize that you've got people
from 30 plus countries and what holds
them all together,
what they share in common is kiss.
I think it's,
it's,
it's so cool because I always go,
you know,
rock bands make music phenomenons,
impacts society,
you know,
and,
and that's,
that's the difference.
And that's what kisses
kisses a phenomenon.
Yeah.
You've bypassed the rockstar status.
Now you're,
you're a phenomenon,
but you can still see
me buying groceries now.
Uh,
the hard rock,
um,
when it does start,
it starts November 5th,
I believe.
How long it's gonna run till it's,
it's that month.
And I know,
well,
I'm sure we'll,
we'll be back.
What happens in Vegas is
worth seeing in Vegas twice.
Yeah.
Um,
so how many nights a week
are you guys doing it?
Three,
three nights away.
So in stays initially it's Wednesdays,
Fridays and Saturdays.
So you just take Thursday off and then,
yeah,
I'd fly over the weekend.
Oh,
you fought him?
Yeah.
Gotcha.
The kids to school.
Could you imagine living
there and doing that?
Um,
I know people who live outside
of Vegas and they like it.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
Penn Jillette seems to love it,
but I was looking at him sideways
when he tells me that like,
hmm.
Did you see,
um,
Tim's Vermeer movie?
He did know what does that,
it's,
um,
a guy,
he knows a,
an inventor and made a lot of money,
had this,
um,
interest in,
in the painter Vermeer and nobody can
quite figure out how Vermeer painted
because,
uh,
he,
he seemed to,
he didn't sketch underneath and,
and his,
his,
um,
handling of light is very,
very unique anyway,
so,
um,
uh,
Penn Intel did this
movie with their friend,
um,
documenting his,
his quest to,
to understand how Vermeer painted.
It's,
it's,
it's fabulous.
It won,
won an academy award I think late
last year or the year before.
I've never heard of this guy before.
What's so unique about his painting?
Vermeer,
um,
was a Dutch painter who,
just seem to,
to understand light in a way that was
photographic as opposed to what you'd see
in normal paintings.
And,
uh,
there's no outlines around anything.
It's almost like he just
painted without ever.
Somehow you looked at
something and painted it and
it's a very interesting film.
It's a documentary,
but fascinating.
And they're the ones behind the film.
Well,
pens,
a very unique thinker and he's also a guy.
No drugs,
no alcohol,
no nothing.
Yeah,
he lives in Vegas,
works in show business.
Was a Carney at one point in time,
you know,
is a professional magician.
You know,
all of those things.
You would think a guy
who's crazy off the rails,
self-destructive.
Nope.
None of the above.
Very,
very intelligent guy,
very introspective,
always in deep thought,
has a great podcast.
Really,
uh,
had a great radio show before that.
He just sees a very unique dude.
You know,
fame gives you the opportunity to have
an amazing life or to kill yourself
with or without it,
right?
Yeah.
Take your choice.
Well,
we're all gonna die.
It's just a matter of when.
So how do people get tickets to the Vegas
thing that get through the hard rock?
I have no idea.
I'm just,
I'm talking guitar player.
I just sing exactly.
Love Gun and Detroit,
rock city.
And stridor and come on and love me
and firehouse and hotter than hell.
And you know,
it.
Shout it out.
Lie.
That's just what I do.
That is what you do.
And uh,
it's been a real privilege,
man.
Thank you very much.
Been an honor to have you on here.
I really,
really appreciate it.
I've been a fan for so long,
so I was like kid in
the candy store today.
Awesome.
Thank you very much.
Thank you Paul Stanley,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's it.
We're done.
Awesome.
Uncle Vinny.